NANDEN SRIDHAR:
My name is Nanden.
I'm a PM with Apigee.
And I'm going to be
talking to guys a bit
about API management and
microservices before I
introduce Gallo from HP.
And he's going to
talk to you guys
about how HP used microservices
and API management
in their transformation.
So let's start off very
quickly with why enterprises
are building microservices-based
architectures
and what's the driving factor?
Two main reasons come to my
mind when enterprises are
talking about microservices.
The first is that they
want to take advantage
of cloud-based infrastructures.
Now, we may all not agree
on what microservices are.
But there's general consensus
on what a microservice's stack
looks like.
And the general idea is that
by building your applications
or workloads to be compatible
with this architecture enables
you to move these
workloads to the cloud.
Even if they don't
move right away,
gives the companies choices
to move to the cloud.
The second big idea
behind microservices--
and we hear this all the time--
is velocity, speed,
agility, and all of this.
Right?
And the problem with
monolith applications
was it took forever to
test it and it took forever
to make production releases.
And microservices
promised an architecture
where you had the ability
to make deployments faster.
So as enterprises started
decomposing their microservices
into independent
units, developers
got the chance to independently
develop, deploy, version, scale
those services.
And these are problems that you
didn't have with microservices.
So in theory, we should
come to the conclusion
that yes, microservices
are awesome.
All problems were solved.
While it is true that
the challenges with speed
and agility were
definitely solved
with a microservices
architecture,
new problems were introduced.
Right?
When you had all
these development
teams building microservices,
governance became a big issue.
Where do I do MTLS?
Where do I do a load balancing?
How do I ensure that the
right telemetry is collected?
Or there's a performance issue.
Every microservices
team says yep,
my service is doing just fine.
And so we saw the advent of
service management tools.
And so a service
management tool is
really catered to the persona
of a service operator.
A service operator
is someone who's
concerned with the
fleet of services
that he or she manages.
And they are entrusted
to apply governance
across these services.
That governance standard could
be MTLS for all my services,
I want to capture telemetry--
not have every microservices
team invent these concepts
for their microservices nor have
these things put into the code
base of your microservices.
Start to think of these
capabilities as available
in the infrastructure itself.
So I get features like
governance, observability,
and basic security into
each of my microservices.
So imagine that you
have microservices
and you're using a tool that
gives you these capabilities.
Is it done?
Is there anything
else that is missing?
Well, when you think
about it, yes, we
have solved the problem
for the service operator
who's looking at these
services in production.
But before services
get to production,
there is a set of
capabilities that we need
for producers and consumers.
So teams that are
building microservices
are often building
microservices that
are consumed by other teams--
teams outside your
zone of trust.
Those other teams could
be in other departments
in your organization, could
even be outside the enterprise.
So when you have teams
outside your enterprise
who are consuming
services, where
do they find your microservices?
How do they know what
the documentation
for your microservices
looks like?
How do they get access
to these services?
And how do you manage that?
So the concept of managing the
relationship between producers
and consumers is critical
to API management.
So a consumer of
your microservice
should go to a
portal, seek access
to a microservice he
or she wants access
to because they're building
other microservices based
on this.
And now comes the
concerns of a provider.
As a provider, I
want to manage who
can access my microservices.
I want to be able to revoke
fair access or grant access.
If I am granting
access, I may want
to grant different degrees of
access to my microservices.
I'll build a microservice once
and have different degrees
of access to internal consumers
versus external consumers.
So at one point,
yes, as a developer--
as a producer, I want
to engage consumers,
I want to control that access,
and then also control what type
of access I want to give them.
So once you've defined who
gets access to my microservices
and how they get access to
it, the next step, obviously,
is to enforce that access--
policy enforcement.
When we think of
policy enforcement,
we really think about a gateway.
A gateway it's
typically a place that's
where you do policy
enforcement, also
known as policy
enforcement points.
I mean, when you think
about API gateways,
there is a picture that
comes to mind or capabilities
that we all expect
API gateways to have.
You want your API
gateways to do things
like rate limitings
or [INAUDIBLE]..
You want those gateways
to verify tokens.
You want the gateways
to even provide
other features not
related to security,
like caching of
requests or responses.
These are all things that we've
come to expect of a gateway.
And when we talk
about API gateways,
a pattern that has
served for many years
is this sort of a
centralized API gateway.
These cluster or
groups of APIs gateways
often serve as a single
entry point into your APIs.
API-- your company name-- would
.com would really be the one
that's receiving the requests,
which is a group of gateways
that are a facade
to all your APIs.
And these gateways did
functions like rate
limiting, checking the token--
did all this in addition
to more advanced features, like
aggregating a bunch of services
to give you the facade
as if they were one.
They also orchestrated other
microservices or services.
And they performed that
function fairly well.
But when you start
thinking about using
this pattern for microservices,
something doesn't always fit.
Right?
It is not uncommon for
a single transaction
from one of your
channels to a back-end go
through a number
of microservices
before it goes to the database.
And as it goes through
your microservices,
it is onerous notice to have
every microservice go back
to a centralized gateway
and hit the database.
Clearly that's not
a viable option.
And so, to deal
with this situation,
we now see patterns that
are sidecar API gateways.
Sometimes that also referred
to as microgateways.
So a sidecar is a process
that runs in the same trust
zone as your microservice.
You really have
to think about it
as an extension of
your application.
It's not something else.
But it's a separate process.
And the application of the
microservice in this case
delegates certain
responsibilities to the sidecar
so you don't have to
implement it yourself.
And a sidecar gateway is
ideal for implementing
allow-deny type of rules.
What are allow-deny
type of rules?
The rate limiting is one-- do
I allow traffic, to block it?
Checking a token or a
key is a allow-deny rule.
Do I allow this
access or deny this?
And they're perfect for this
sort of a scenario, which
is typically what we see when
you have microservices calling
other microservices.
So does that mean that
that's the only pattern that
fits microservices, that
everything is a sidecar
gateway?
But our position is that
you don't necessarily
have to choose.
You could have an
intelligent ingress
that is able to
decide for every API,
should this API be
enforced by a sidecar
or should this be enforced by
a more centralized gateway?
And you could use
various techniques
to discriminate what
type of a gateway
needs to enforce
policies on this.
So based on a verb, a path,
something in the header,
you could route traffic
to a centralized gateway
to get more advanced functions
for it because that API needs
it, or it could be directly
routed to a sidecar
because that is all
what was needed.
And there will be some
cases which really
go through both gateways.
And that's perfectly
fine, too, as long
as you're not duplicating
functionality.
So the other thing
to remember as you're
building microservices
is that not everything
in your enterprise is
going to be a microservice.
Yeah, sure, you're all
in the transition phase
where you're building
applications and that.
But there are also other
types of applications
in your enterprise.
Most enterprises will
still have a good set
of SOA-based services that are
trying to modernize slowly.
Enterprises are being forced
to expose a lot of their APIs
to the public--
you know, standards
like open banking
are forcing banks to have
public-facing APIs, things
that didn't happen
three, four years ago.
So as an enterprise,
you're going
to have a combination of
all these requirements.
Also not uncommon
is for enterprises
to invoke APIs built
by other vendors--
Salesforce, Workday,
these are all APIs
that you want to make available.
It's not really nice to have
your microservices developer
get another OAR
token for Salesforce,
get an OAR token internally
and have to manage all this.
It'd be really nice to have
some sort of token mediation
so your microservices
developer deals with one
type of an access
token that gets
mediated between different
types of standards.
So our recommendation is that
when building microservices,
use a service management tool.
Most service management
tools, like Istio or Linkerd,
they come with a sidecar.
And as much as possible,
use the sidecar
to act as your
sidecar API gateway.
So in the case of Istio,
one way would be that sort
of a sidecar API gateway.
And for cases where do you need
a more centralized gateway,
think about a centralized
API management
platform that is able to
offer these capabilities.
So Apigee has a gateway
that gives you capabilities
for all these form factors.
We have the
enterprise API gateway
that we have now had for
about six or seven years.
And it's been
running in production
with many of our customers.
But we have also introduced
two types of gateways--
the microgateway for customers
who have not yet adopted
a service mesh like Istio.
And we have built the
Apigee adapter for Istio
for enterprises that
have started to adopt
Istio for service management.
The key point here is that the
API management platform becomes
a central control plane
through which you can control
different classes of
gateways depending
on the needs of your enterprise.
So with this quick
introduction, I
invite Gallo now
to talk about how
HP use some of
these technologies
at their enterprise.
GALLO GIMENEZ-PALOP:
OK, thank you, Nanden.
OK, so my name is Gallo Gimenez.
I work at HP at the
office of this CTO,
where we are basically building
infrastructure and core
services that support our
devices and our applications.
I've been in HP for
more than 20 years now.
And during those
years, almost 15 years
I have basically been
in distributed systems.
So I won't go into the numbers.
HP was a company that
was found that in 1939.
So it's very old company
for Silicon Valley.
In 2015, the company
was reinvented to focus
on three areas--
one is basically HP
computing, so things like
workstations and Chromebooks.
The other one is printing.
So with all things from $29
printers to several million
dollar printers.
And the last one is
3D manufacturing.
One of the important
things that we have here
is that HP is operating
in 170 countries.
So that means that
compliance and are
regulations had an important
aspect of everything
that we do.
And I'm going to
basically talk how
we use the cloud and the service
meshes and practice to do that.
So in HP, there is
like three trends
that are affecting
the way we do things.
One is what we call One Life.
One Life is basically
the blending
of our personal and
professional life.
So we use the same devices
for the work and play.
The other one is as-a-service.
So the work to market is
changing from a transactional
to contractual.
So you can see this
in IT organizations
of loading their operations
through other groups.
So basically they don't have
to deploy, manage, and secure
services.
And the last one is
security and privacy--
which is obviously with
more devices connected,
consumers and
organizations are basically
consuming and producing
very valuable data
that we need to protect.
OK?
So these trends basically
set the direction
of our organization.
And then in our
organization, there
is basically two
groups that have
a big say in how we do cloud.
One is IT.
IT, with the change
in 2015, decided
not to focus anymore
on data centers,
and migrate everything
to the public cloud.
And obviously IT traditionally
focuses on security and cost.
My group, the CTO office,
basically traditionally we
focus on things
such as innovation.
We try to bring best
practices from the industry
into the tech communities in HP.
And then because we are
a neutral organization,
we took on the work of
doing these shared services
across other organizations.
Finally, my group
is very focused
on privacy and
security, especially
for global applications because
all the markets where we are.
So-- sorry, I need to go back.
So this basically defines our
strategy for how we do cloud.
I mean, there is nothing that
should surprise you here.
So basically we
are a cloud native
because we are in
the public cloud.
We do Agile, we do continuous
delivery and integration.
We do dev ops.
And because we have
this shared services,
contracts are very
important for us.
And for us, contracts are
basically APIs and SLAs.
Security and privacy,
as I said, these
are very important role for
both IT and the CT office.
And finally, microservices
is part of our strategy.
And what I'm going
to explain to you
is how we do microservices
at HP and why we do it.
OK?
So why we do microservices--
the real reason
is basically for
product velocity.
We are building
these applications.
Initially, these
applications will
be built by very large
teams with many people.
And this required a
lot of synchronization
between those teams.
These teams usually in
different functional areas
of the application will have
dependencies across them.
And sometimes the
dependencies were circular.
So basically this required
even more meetings
to solve those dependencies.
We had this continuous
integration pipelines
that would take hours.
And because there were
so many dependencies,
there were manual gates
to decide if something was
moving or not moving forward.
Right?
So, at the end, the
result was that features
will take very long,
much more longer
than what all we wanted
to put into production.
So with microservices,
what we were looking for
was to increase the
product velocity.
So we have a smaller code base
that our teams can handle.
We tried to have those smart
applications and services go
into production
independently so they
don't have to have the
dependencies with other teams.
We have a smaller teams so the
communication in those smaller
teams is less.
So we have less communication.
It's more efficient, because
we can have these smaller
teams usually co-located.
And then because they
are smaller teams,
they can on the whole
application is done.
So they can own
how the application
is developed, coded, tested,
moved into production.
And they are usually operating
in those applications
themselves.
So they are on pager
duty, they get the alerts.
And they own the whole thing.
So we call it you
build it, you run it.
But when we started to
do the microservices,
obviously microservices
are more complicated
that monolith applications.
Microservices have lots
of technical problems.
So the first one we found
was infrastructure cost.
Suddenly, we have
all these VMs, right?
And these VMs became
very expensive.
Because we have
many of those VMs
for every single service
and different environments
for every service.
We had dozens and dozens
of continuous integration
on pipelines, right?
Because now you have
many, many, many services.
Orchestration and discovery
becomes way more complicated
because services depend
on other services.
So you need to know where
the other service is
as in which environment
are you running--
are you in production or in VA?
And basically, you have to
depend on the other service
to be there in order for your
service to start working.
There is challenges that
are traditional and normal
in these [INAUDIBLE] systems.
You have latency variance.
And you have network partitions.
You need to deal with
distributed transactions
across different services.
So those are very hard
problems to solve sometimes.
We have problems with
dependency versions.
Now you have services that
depend on other services.
And those other services have
new versions continuously.
So how do you know which
is the other version
of the other service and
when the other team changes
the version of the service?
Integration testing became
really, really difficult
because now, when you
release one of the services,
you need to do the
integration testing
with a bunch of other
testing other services.
And finally, the problem
which I'm going to focus now
is basically policy spread.
So this is an example
of an application
with several microservices.
I call them A, B,
and C. And usually
you are going to have that
you have more than one version
of those services-- so we call
them alpha, beta, gamma, and so
on.
And these services
may be managing
different types of data.
Some of the data is personal.
Some of the data is data that
is not sensitive or doesn't
contain personal
information, and so on.
And your mesh-- and you
might think that this
is a very complex application.
But as soon as you start
to do microservices,
you will find that
it's very easy
to get in a complicated
mess like this.
Now, you will end up
deploying this application
in multiple data centers
or Kubernetes clusters,
whatever you deploy.
And your mesh might even
get more complicated.
So you will have, on
top of A, B, and C,
and alpha, beta, and gamma,
you are going to have A-prime
and alpha-prime, right?
And the decision of where
do you deploy things
in the different
data centers, it
might depend on cost
considerations or latency
considerations, right?
So this mesh is going to get
more messy and complicated.
So when you look
at the things you
need to do in all
of these services,
you will see that you are
repeating things over and over.
So basically, you need to apply
things such as authorization,
authentication, you need
to do payload inspection,
you need to do rates, you
need to do quotas, right?
And you do this over, and
over, and over, and over
in every single place.
In the worst case, you
are going to be doing
this in different languages.
Because those services
might be implemented
in different languages.
Some might be note applications.
Some might be Go applications.
Some might be Java applications.
So at the end, you have policy
spread all over the place.
It is very difficult
to understand what
is your position about policy.
You don't have any
visibility about what
is going on in the system.
And worse, it is very easy
to have a single mistake that
is going to screw
up-- basically is
going to bring your system
to a very bad situation.
So the good news is
there is things that can
help to solve this problems.
So one of the technologies
that helps our containers
in Kubernetes,
they basically help
us to have more density
in our deployments.
They solve some of the
programs around orchestration
and discovery.
The other one is API management.
So now we can have
written contracts
with the consumers of our
APIs that we can version.
And we can have visibility about
how our consumers are using
the APIs of different services.
We have API gateways and
proxies that basically
allows that to centralize
some of the policies,
as Nanden described before.
So we can have things
such as authorization
and authentication centralized
in a single location,
or payload inspection.
And finally, with
the service mesh,
we can go further and have
additional network policies
implemented by the mesh.
So we can have things such
as traffic encryption,
or basically balancing
between services, and so on.
OK?
So I'm going to focus
on the last ones.
So in HP, we have different
applications, as everybody.
So we have everything
from latency
to very new application.
And we have these
three different models,
as Nanden described it,
about how we do these things.
So the first thing is we
have a monolith applications.
These applications,
sometimes they
are deployed in
governance clusters.
Sometimes they are
deployed in VMs, right?
But we still need to have this
common control plane where
we want to put the policies.
In this case, we use
this centralized proxy
that basically
takes the policies
such as authentication,
authorization, and rate limits,
and that's the
location where we are.
In the case where we have
this important coordinators
or in the case
where we have VMs,
there is no difference, right?
Newer applications that we
started a few years ago,
we started to use the
sidecar container paradigm.
So basically, we
embed microgateway
in front of our services.
So basically, our continuous
integration pipeline,
when you deploy one
of those services,
injects a safeguard
container into the box.
And that sidecar
container, in our case--
we base it on APG's
microgateway--
it's connected to the
APG control plane.
So we can manage some
of the policies there.
Now, many of the policies
we cannot manage through
the control plane.
They need to be embedded
into the microgateway itself.
So basically, our continuous
integration pipeline
configuration
management mechanism
is making sure we have
the right policies there.
Still, this is a
little bit problematic
because basically the
microgateway for service A
and the microgateway for service
B might be different, right?
So the last services
that we are building,
we are leveraging Istio.
The difference with
the previous model I
showed you before is now that
you have this common control
plane when you can manage a very
large freight of microgateways
or proxies.
So you have all their policies
managed in a single place.
So you don't need to
have different versions
of these microgateway for
the different services.
You can manage this centrally.
Another interesting
thing about Istio,
it provides just not
policies on the ingress,
but you can have policies
also in the egress.
So you can control to whom
your services are talking.
Or you can white-list or
blacklist some services
where you don't want
the traffic to go.
OK?
So I'm going to show you
a couple of applications
where do use this.
So this is one of the
largest applications
that we have right now.
It's HP-ID.
Basically, HP-ID is the HP
Identity Management system.
So if you hold the HP.com
you have a printer that
is connected to the
cloud, your identity
is managed by this system.
This application right now is
running in three data centers.
Basically we have three regions.
And we have coordinated
cluster in every region.
In this case, we are using
the microgateway model.
You can see these
orange bubbles there.
That's the microgateway
that we inject
in front of the services.
And the traffic is sent to the
clusters through an ingress.
In this case, we
are using Nginx.
You will notice that
some of our bots
have just the microgateway.
And the reason is we have
some back-end services that
are still run on VMs.
They are not in this diagram.
And we also proxy the
traffic to those services
through microgateways.
So basically, we apply
a consistent way of-- we
have a consistent
way of applying
this policies to everything that
we have in our infrastructure.
In this case, we decided to put
the microgateway in Kubernetes
because it's, for us,
far easier to scale,
to manage, and to release than
having those microgateways
deployed in VMs with
the services that
are in the back-end.
OK?
This is another application.
This is our content
management system.
So most of our devices
deal with content--
scan or printed content.
And the content goes
through the cloud.
And this system basically is
what manages that content.
So, in this case, the system is
deployed to data centers, one
in the US and one in Europe.
And we are basically
using Istio.
So what we are
basically doing here
is we replace Nginx
by the Istio gateway.
So the traffic goes
into the Istio gateway.
And then we have Envoy
inject that automatically
by the Istio system in
front of our services.
The good thing about
Istio is that Apigee
has integrated this with their
control plane on the cloud.
So basically, we can have
consistent authentication
and authorization policies
for all of services
independently of what
is the mechanism we
use to deploy those services.
And that's it.
I'll let Nanden--
NANDEN SRIDHAR:
Thank you, Gallo.
So obviously, we can show the
actual systems that HP uses.
But we've got a demo that kind
of shows you these technologies
and how they kind
of come together.
So in this demo, we
took a simple example
to illustrate the point.
It's a retail example that
has a bunch of services.
Right?
The first is an order API.
And you have a consumer that's
outside your zone of trust--
could be a mobile
app, online app,
or whatever it is that's making
a request to the order API.
The order API calls the
inventory microservice.
They're both built
as microservices.
And that shows you some
service-to-service connectivity
there, with one of
these services that's
exposed outside.
And depending on
certain conditions,
the order API could
also invoke and place
an order on Salesforce
with a partner then.
And that's how they're exposed--
that interfaced
with this order API.
So what this example would look
like when actually implemented
with gateways is that you
would have a common ingress
point to this application--
API.retailcompany.com, right?
And your order APIs
are obviously--
that that's the facade
the request comes to.
And then the
ingress then decides
what to deal with this-- or how
to deal with this API request.
Because this request is
coming from the outside,
you generally would
want to scan the payload
to make sure the JSONs font does
not exceed certain capacity.
And you want to do this general
check because it's coming
from a untrusted network.
And that's-- what you
see as Message Processor,
that's the name for Apigee's
centralized or enterprise API
gateway.
The gateway then hands it off
to the order microservice.
All of these are running in
Kubernetes at this point.
The order microservice
then calls the inventory
microservice.
But except this
time, it does not
have to go back to that
centralized gateway
even though it's in
the same cluster.
It now calls the
microgateway, which
is the only facade the
inventory service exposes--
so there is no way
to bypass the gateway
and go directly to
the inventory service.
And of course,
there's now a call-out
that the order-- now the order
API needs to call Salesforce.
But obviously I don't
want the order API
to code for Salesforce's
access tokens and all that.
It's already got an
access token with it.
And that's what it uses
to call Salesforce.
So this time, in the order
API [INAUDIBLE] vendor
API, it calls that
API without knowing
what this vendor's
authentication authorization
mechanism is.
But the centralized gateway
manages this token mediation
and does this on behalf
of the order API.
And of course, at
the end of all this,
we are going to see
some analytics to see
how all these APIs are being
used, who's using them,
and so on and so forth.
All right, so with that,
let's go see the demo.
Demo, please.
All right, so I've got a single
Kubernetes cluster on GKE,
where I've got my applications
and microservices installed.
And I'm going to
use my CLI to show
you what exactly is running.
Let me go here.
So I'm going to quickly show
you the actual microservices.
So Demo is the
name space I have.
And this is where I've got
those two microservices.
I don't know if that's
big enough for you guys.
But if you guys can see-- no?
OK, I wish you hadn't said that.
Because I don't know how
to increase the font.
Sorry, I'll read it out.
There are two
microservices there--
the order and the
inventory microservice.
And I know it's hard to
tell, but one of them
is a part with two containers
in it, one of which
has the microgateway.
OK, so now that we have seen the
applications that are running,
we'll very quickly show
you the Apigee components
that are running also
on the same gateway.
This uses the recently
announced Apigee hybrid,
which runs the
enterprise gateway
on any platform of your choice.
So this is running now on GKE.
So I've got all my
gateway infrastructure
running in a remote installation
that's now getting instructions
from a central control plane
that's managed by Apigee.
So I've got my Apigee
components running.
It's also got Istio in it.
And we'll see how
they work together.
OK, so now what
I'm going to do is
I'm going to try and
gain access to a part,
just to kind of
show you to see if I
can bypass some of
the security systems,
and access these services.
So usually, you would
restrict such access
to Kubernetes [INAUDIBLE].
But this time, just to show you
that the services are indeed
protected, I'm going to get
into one of these services.
I've gotten access
to one of the pods.
And now I'm going to try and
access the service directly.
So I'm going to call the
inventory service from a part
that's running in Kubernetes.
And if everything works good,
I should get an error message.
I get a Missing
Authorization because I'm--
even though I'm
inside the cluster,
I'm running in another part.
I can't access it.
Because there's
a sidecar gateway
that's protecting all
of these microservices.
But if I got access to
the inventory service,
I should then be able
to get access to it.
So now if I've
changed my persona
from being a service operator
who was worried about this
to being a developer
off the order service
who wants to invoke the
inventory service, what I would
do is go to the
Developer Portal.
And now, this is a quick example
of the portal that we have.
And I go look at
all the services
that exist in my catalog.
And now you can
control access to what
microservices I should see.
Internal developers probably
will see most of the catalog.
And external developers may not.
And once I have seen the
APIs that I'm interested in,
I could even try accessing
some of these APIs from here,
see how they operate.
So for example, I'm going to
take order as an example here.
Although I am building the
order service, in this example
I'm going to assume that I want
to consume the order service.
I'm going to quickly try
and gain some access to it,
look at how the API works.
I see the response.
I get some
documentation about it.
It looks like I'm mostly
good to start building
my application based on this.
But there's one
important step missing.
I never got access to this API.
And that's what I'll do next.
Right?
Now, of course I
pre-created these.
But what I would do is go
to my Application Access
and then look at--
and then request access
to the APIs here.
So here, I already
created, pre-created
this, where I've gotten access
to the order application.
I've got a client
ID and a secret.
So I can get by
OAR tokens for it.
And I can use these tokens
to access my service.
And this is what a typical
developer would do.
Now, assuming I've
got this client ID,
now I'm going to try and
access the inventory service
because I now have credentials
to access that service.
So this time, I'm
going to go back
to the same Kubernetes pod.
But this time I'm going
to access it with a key.
So now that I accessed it with
a key, I get a HTTP 200 back.
I could use minus-V. And then
you guys will see the response.
It's kind of unfortunate that
the font is not big enough.
My terminal doesn't
support changing that.
Sorry about that.
OK, so now that we have kind
of protected my east-west
traffic--
microservice-to-microservice
communication--
let's take a quick look at how
I would protect it for traffic
coming from the outside.
So what I'm going to do next
is very quickly show you
how that setup looks like.
If you look at the
containers that I have,
I have the inventory container
and the microgateway container
in the same pod.
So the microgateway
will scale and get
upgraded each time I deploy
the pod for inventory.
OK, so now let's go take
a example about trying
to access a partner API.
So in this case, that partner
API would be Salesforce.
I'm not even going to try
and send a parameter to it.
I'll send an empty body to
show you that the partners
API is protected.
So I'm going to send this
empty string to the partner AP.
You'll notice two things.
First, that wasn't a
Salesforce endpoint.
I use Fazio.
Fazio is the name I made
up for the retail service.
So I still use my internal
host name or domain name
to access this API.
The second, it was protected.
And so I got an Access
Denied because I didn't
have the tokens to access it.
Now what I would again do
is go back to the portal
and seek access to this API like
any other API in my enterprise
because I don't care what
the partner implemented.
So now let me go grab a token.
So I'm going to connect
to my token endpoint
and pass in the client
credentials drawn
because that's easy to show.
And I'm going to go get
an access token for it.
So now that I've gotten
this access token,
I'm going to try and access
the partner's API now.
And-- let's fix that.
And put the--put the token in.
And send in the body.
All right, so my
order was submitted.
Now I'm going to quickly
log into Salesforce
and show you that my
order got created.
So if everything worked
fine, I had 15 orders.
I'm going to do a quick refresh.
Hopefully there's a 16th
one that just came in.
And that was created through
the enterprise gateway
that I just created now.
So there's a quick demo to
show three different use
cases, some east-west traffic
being protected, [INAUDIBLE],,
and some token mediation.
Thank you all.